so where we're talking about elite level
athletes in terms of randori in terms of
rep like uh drilling
for more recreational athletes
like
you know i have personally that
situation going on but there's other
people there just recreationally
training judo
how do you recommend they improve judo
like
if i wanted to compete a bunch
and do reason reasonable with a
particular set of throws say the split
uh that's what it
say nagi so how do you how do you do you
do the randori do you use a crash brad
to get him reps do you like what do you
recommend so i guess there's two
recreational people that we're talking
about one is somebody who wants to learn
judo and become good at judo but don't
doesn't necessarily want to compete but
just wants to get better and i think
that there's not enough emphasis
in this country on
just that on paying attention to that
type of student everybody pushes them to
competition but in reality there's a
huge audience of people out there that
would love to learn judo and be very
proficient at judo and have the skills
to go execute if they ever needed it
and there's a class and there should be
a program for that athlete and that
athlete does not need to do randori
like the sport of judo is physical
enough when you're picking somebody up
all the time and moving their body
weight around the mat all the time you
can get very physically strong very
physically fit
technically you'll be better than
somebody that does randori more than you
because you're move if you learn good
technique and you learn the movement and
you learn the feel and you move the
learn the timing
you'll actually be a better athlete than
the person that just focuses on randori
who does ugly technique and wins with
force so you know we have a recreational
class at our school where they don't do
any randori they have an option
afterwards if they want to stay for 15
minutes or stay for 30 minutes where
they can participate in randori but most
of the adult students choose not to
because they're already so tired from
the other you know good workout right
they're already dripping sweat they're
already like if you if you
you know work hard and drill hard it's
an intense workout you're exhausted
you know so that that's a specific
set of of a program i should say at
every academy and then
if you want to get good and you want to
compete
then to me once you have your techniques
it's learning how to
implement a good gripping system to put
yourself in a position where you can
always you know dominate the grips
control the movement initiate the
reactions from your opponent and then
have the opportunity to attack and score
and and i think that when people train
with or when they jump into a higher
level of the sport of judo all of a
sudden the first thing they say is i
can't attack like i don't know how to
attack because positionally they don't
know where to put their hands they don't
know how to hold the ghee properly they
don't understand that they're
you know they have an inferior grip
and and they don't know how to get into
better positions so they can attack and
that's a big part of the game that not a
lot of people really understand so you
really even for recreational competitors
you really need to have a gripping
system you need to understand the
gripping system
if you want to win yeah i mean if the
goal is to go and compete that's a
different story you're going i don't
have fun getting beat up or losing in
competitions i i enjoy the
i don't even know if it's the winning or
the losing i don't
i i think
this is what because i competed a lot in
both jiu-jitsu and in judo
it feels like because i didn't have a
gripping system it feels like you're not
even playing judo against the the good
black belts you're they're just they're
not they're not even trying because they
have they get a certain kind of grip and
you just can't do anything and i don't
have a good answer for that i don't even
know what i'm looking for and so it's
not even fun it's not like even losing
it's it's like um
i don't know it's like you didn't even
show up to play
is what it feels like and it's
unfortunate i i think that is a big gap
in knowledge actually
in um
judo schools
is
is the gripping part
when you first go out to to
do judo right you the first thing you
have to do is you have to grab your
opponent right and a lot of times the
hair coaches say get a grip just take a
grip well sometimes if you take a grip
you're in a worse position than not
having a grip at all and that's what a
lot of people don't understand like if
you hold the gui in the wrong way your
opponent can attack you but you can't
attack him so why would you ever do that
grip
if it's only to your detriment
right so that's and
the way you grip does set up
what attacks you can do as well so that
is a huge part and i'm not saying that
you have to be 100 disciplined and only
always outgrip your opponent and only be
able to do throws when you have a
superior grip i'm just saying that
to be able to put the grips together
with the throws and understand the
movements is going to make you that much
ahead of the game
you